suicida the author of tokyo ghoul
what can only be described as one of the
past decades most
iconic anime and manga has finally put
out the debut chapter of his new manga
under shonen jump chojin x
calling this manga highly anticipated is
an understatement
and the first chapter already sets up a
promising foundation
for the symbolism and philosophical
questions into human nature that is
known for from
tokyo ghoul and so today i'm looking at
the first and only chapter out so far
and my favorite or the most important
moments i see from it
how excited i am for trojan x another
manga from suicida
and where i see this dark series going
in the future with shonen jump
let's dive right in right after you
subscribe of course
don't be part of that 96 percent the
support would be huge for the growing
channel
let's roll my intro
now i'm not going to give a huge summary
of the chapter and what happens because
well most people watching this will
probably have read it and
i mean if you haven't i don't want to
ruin that experience for you
because it does have a formidable length
of 82 pages as well so there's a lot to
unpack and each detail would just be
kind of tedious
so instead i'm going to focus on four
main things
the meaning of a trojan both in the
words actual definition
and how it'll pan out in the manga the
roly-poly analogy one of the biggest
points of symbolism in this chapter
the dynamic between the two main
protagonists and the future of dark
manga in shonen jump
and how they're beginning to honestly
take over
and so first what is a trojan
now in japanese chojin refers to a
superhuman
superman to be more specific but i
assume within a broader context in this
manga
it won't be limited to just one gender
and the title actually does remind me of
trojan x's older brother in shonen jump
kaiju number 8 in its title and its
concept
something very interesting to note
however is the irony of these
in that kaiju number eight kaiju meaning
monster in japanese
is a much more light slightly comedic
set manga compared to the
already very dark trojan x where the
idea of a superhuman or superman
being kind of a brighter hero is
contradicted
though that stereotype is beginning to
be broken down anyways especially with
new hits like
invincible which turned the idea of what
a heroic icon is on its head
and have turned what are expected to be
superhero typical
cartoons into a darker more mature and
realistic take on the genre
regardless though it will probably a
situation of one of
if not both of our main characters
taking on a heroic
trojan role something that is hinted at
in the chapter itself
and especially considering azuma's very
stand up and stoic personality
already i could definitely see this
happening but just
considering suicide's style and if we
can take any semblance of what will
happen from tokyo ghoul
it won't be as peachy as that they get
away with doing whatever they want it's
something of an affliction
the series will definitely develop very
serious tones further on
on what it means to be a trojan and the
temptation of power itself
of being able to do anything you want
and i'll come back to this later when i
talk about azume and tokyo specifically
but before that i want to move on to the
second topic which is the conversation
about yes roly-polies
the conversation between azuma and tokyo
begins with them discussing a terrorist
attack from a trojan
noted specifically to be another trojan
by ozuma as well
at this point in society in the manga we
can already tell
that children are bad they get away with
what they want
and from the conversation between these
two it seems that there's never really
been one to come to light who is
actually using their power for good
and thus the conversation about roly
polies begins
osuma tells tokyo the reason roly-polies
gather under rocks
they're active in dry places they keep
moving and moving
and they stop only when it's damp so
once they reach a rock they nest and
gather beneath it simply because
it's no longer dry and so azuma raises
the question
do you think roly-polies like damp
places
though it's assumed that they would
because they always stop there
it might simply because it's no longer
dry because their instinct forces them
to stop in a damp place
rather than them particularly enjoying
it
and then he wonders if children are in
fact like roly-polies
what he's questioning is essentially in
a very roundabout way
whether trojans like to commit terrorist
attacks to act with evil intentions
aka whether they would like to stop in
those dark damp places
or whether it's just their nature
kicking in if it's just something they
biologically have to do or do even
without wanting to
it raises the question of whether there
are no good children because
no one wants to be good or because
trojan physically can't be
this will likely be an important
self-questioning both of our main
characters will have to go through later
in the series
considering they are both probably we
can't tell with azuma yet
chojin now dealing with similar themes
to tokyo ghoul the conflict between
human morals and the natural desires and
actions of being a trojan
will be a huge driving force in this
series i'm sure
and now the two main protagonists tokyo
the main character
and azuma who is a bit more of a side
character or rival figure
and their relationship will definitely
be important in the future of this manga
their dynamic does remind me somewhat of
hide and kaneki from tokyo ghoul
not a lot but just in the way that tokyo
similar to kaneki
is much more introverted and soft-spoken
while azuma reminds me of hide's more
outgoing and expressive attitude
you can definitely see many of the same
motifs and stylistic decisions from
tokyo ghoul here
what the author likes to play on and so
i'm excited to see how suicida manages
to switch it all up and keep it fresh
tokyo almost just always follows what
azuma does
he calls him over if there's trouble
goes somewhere with him if he asks
even buys a book about insects after
their conversation about roly-polies
at the end of the chapter in his effort
to do anything he can to help azuma and
following his leave
he takes the injection with him to
become a trojan
it'll be very interesting to see how
tokyo grows out of his shell
becomes more independent when a separate
from azuma and
i'm sure having the power of being a
trojan will help along those means
to make him stronger more confident in
himself
and i think that this very wholesome
goal right now that they have of
beating the bad guys of preserving
justice
will probably get twisted as we continue
as they both cope with what it means to
be a trojan
and maybe deal with the consequences of
being one that we're hinted at
in the roly-poly conversation the darker
and uncontrollable side of being a
children that they won't be able to
suppress
i'm excited to see how it'll affect
their close and almost teacher-student
kind of relationship as it is
whether one will get drunk with power
whether tokyo will take the upper hand
there's a lot of potential ways it could
go in my eyes
and the last point is just a broader
discussion about the maturity we're
seeing in shonen jump nowadays
with jujutsu kaisen chainsaw man and the
recently finished hell's paradise
we're witnessing a huge shift of tastes
and shown a jump to favor
darker and more mature manga it's
something that i've really loved to see
grow
and so i definitely think trojan x if
done right
considering the dark foundation that has
already been set in recent years by the
aforementioned manga
plus having a huge name and reputation
from suicida pushing it along
it can definitely go far and further
usher in this wave
it's definitely got a lot of potential
and i know this might feel rushed to say
considering it
really only has been a single chapter
but i don't know i feel good about it
ignoring the anime adaptation ishida did
very well with the tokyo ghoul manga
and so i'm sure there won't be a problem
in trojan x
what did you guys think of the chapter i
enjoyed it i'm looking forward to seeing
where it'll go
definitely leave a comment down below
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
[Music]